só se usa mais o vídeo e hoje vou estar
na minha segunda opção dos carros
elétricos na primeira versão tinha três
grandes problemas um deus é que a roda
não foi de maneira estrelas muito fácil
- não conseguir alguns idade máxima e só
para vocês terem idéia é confiada 30
quilômetros com esse carro aqui o mais
mais de 130 quilos facebook e depois um
problema maior era que quando parava de
acelerar o que esperava a fundo e isso
acabou por estragar todo o sistema tanta
corrente como a rosa e conseguiu
resolver os problemas nessa versão e
vocês vão conseguir ver no vídeo como eu
fiz isso e claro vocês quiserem fazer a
mesma coisa basta enviar um uma metáfora
minha página do facebook poderão enviar
dos fiéis poema é isso agora o estado
vai lá
[Música]
o
e pronto faltando fios para que vocês
tenham gostado do projeto ainda tem dois
problemas um deus é que é 48 plástico km
vai estragar subemprego a precisar de
uma correta no total e o grande problema
aqui é o sistema de travagem que não
funciona muito bem então provavelmente
vocês vão ter cuidado para que elas
maior quanto maior melhor
até a próxima